foreign
what I like about anime is that a lot of
times the medium doesn't shy away from
showing those realities and possible
consequences or lack thereof those also
while the Forgiveness ESOP is offering a
lot of anime often in battle Shonen we
also see some key moments when bullies
get their comeuppance it's a mixed bag
they're all in all and today we'll be
talking about the latter after all while
I don't promote violence it's really
more fun and satisfying to see the
bullies get what's coming to them right
that's just who a lot of us are and
these bullies do need to be taught a
lesson sometimes you know so strap
yourselves in come with me on a ride
that features anime bullies whether the
schoolyard type or ones outside school
settings get their comeuppance
now let's be honest haven't you had that
time when you wanted to strike back at
bullies or people who look down at you
shigaraki in his younger years took
matters in his own hands and he made
those thugs pay in a show that would
have any kid drunk with power it's these
moments that are both sad and gratifying
no wait should those thugs be allowed to
go Scott for free with their bullying
but this way of shigaraki following his
heart soon leads him down to the path of
villainy truly a tough dilemma if you
ask me him the weak shigaraki has been
extinguished and the future symbol of
fear was born in this very moment it's a
chilling moment for two very contrasting
reasons conflicting feelings on this one
but it's something that drives so close
to home
ironically I don't see a silent voice in
a lot of discussion about bullies
getting their comeuppance because it's
an entire movie devoted to The Bullying
oftentimes I see a lot of the community
talk about bullies getting their
comeuppance and of all those times this
is the first anime I immediately think
of needless to say our protagonist shoya
gets the worst of it is definitely not
the only one at fought for shock or
transferring schools but he's the one
who gets the full brunt of the backlash
resulting from it causing his life to go
on a downward spiral shoya getting what
he deserved was the impetus to get the
plot going and set him on his course to
Redemption a silent Voice by all means
is a beautiful story about human nature
forgiveness and turning a new leaf and
it won't ever be possible if shoya
didn't get this on the other hand I feel
that the other classmates Got Away
scot-free for my liking yep they all
suffered in their own ways in the movie
to varying degrees but how fate and
Karma hit them back just doesn't compare
to what shoya had to go through maybe
that's why a silent voice doesn't get
talked about too often in the topic of
bullying it's a movie instead of a
series and the other bullies don't
suffer nearly enough to pay for their
past Behavior
the light novel adaptation with Axel
world now with a fatty like that as a
protagonist we all know is coming sooner
or later don't we ironically enough the
moment that I'll be talking about comes
at the final Arc of the anime adaptation
yet haruyuki had experienced a lot of
crap with bullying and being shunned
prior to this but it was now me seiji
who took things to another level even
involving haru's two friends in this
crap manipulation rumor spreading
blackmail some NTR Vibes Naomi is pretty
much the epitome of a hate sink if
you've seen one he's rightfully hated by
so many people who've watched this anime
but that's what makes his eventual
demise look oh so satisfying even his
supposed sad backstory doesn't change
anything not when he spends an entire
art gloating about stealing the
protagonist Powers turning their girl
into his side and bragging about all
that he can do with his powers Axel
world is one of the first video game
series I've been very immersed in and at
that point I never felt as much
catharsis as seeing Chi you pull the
reverse UNO card and revealed that she's
been the one playing all the time just
to leech off his skills before turning
back to the good guy's side the whole
Ark makes seeing Naomi's final groveling
form so satisfying just before he's
executed and exiled from the game for
good
Tokyo Avengers is a curious case why not
consider giyomasa's faction bullies in
the pure sense of the word that's all to
the expectation of them being you know
thugs running a fight club that's in
contrast to the previous examples who
are all students that you shouldn't have
the expectations of being such big
[ __ ] regardless the starting Arc of
Tokyo Avengers really left a bad
impression on me thanks to takimichi's
treatment it's not bad impression in a
sense of me just like in the show but a
bad impression in a sense that I really
wanted kiyomasa to get beat and
takimichi just tried that in a
cliffhanger and that had me also hyped
it's the classic Underdog finally Rises
up against the bully story turns out
it's not our protagonist who gets the
finishing blow but the dynamic duo of
draken and Mikey it feels oh so great to
see this scrub get put in his place by
the real head honchos and it must have
been really humiliating for someone like
him who talks too big it must have felt
like a kick to the balls for kill omasa
and I mean that quite literally
[Music]
and yes the famous elephant lead scene
it's a scene that's not for the faint of
heart not just because of the violence
but because of the people involved for
the entries that I've listed so far the
perpetrators are either teenagers who
mostly ran their mouth and beat people
up or kids with pranks gone horribly
wrong however none of them come as close
to the heartlessness as these people
from Elfin lead and their kids for God's
sakes 11 year olds I don't think the kid
versions of the silent voice
protagonists would be as heartless as
outright beating Lucy's only friend a
dog to death in front of her it's a
level of graphic violence that could
have been laughed at as an attempt at
being edgy but that scene legitimately
pissed quite a few viewers off including
me so to no one's surprise no one shed a
tear when Lucy Unleashed her powers and
just massacred those bullies people say
that violence is never the answer and
one I'd personally prefer a world
without conflict you can't help it when
bullied kids strike back and it's sad to
say in the real world fighting back
often in rather violent ways is also the
only way to stop the whole bullying
things a lot of times realistically
speaking foreign
next is Fruits Basket
I'll tell you a mildly interesting thing
about Fruits Basket one of the most
beloved Shoujo series of all time if you
go on YouTube and type in Fruits Basket
one of the first suggestions you'll get
is Fruits Basket bully scene I guess
that's just how big of a moment this is
for fans of the show and I'm sure a lot
of them get a kick out of watching the
whole thing unfold and I don't blame him
in the slightest Episode 22 of the 2019
remake is a roller coaster of emotions
seeing saki's entire backstory unfold
just gives us a glimpse of how sick some
children really are I wouldn't be
surprised to know people who found the
live Newt scene extremely revolting the
Fiasco's not to the brutal extent of the
Elfin lead one a while ago but it is
just as bad the sad thing is that I
believe that something like this does
happen in a lot of schools in real life
that's why I couldn't care less about
the boys when saki unleashes her powers
on them in a fit of rage she even tries
holding herself back while doing it the
sad part of this is that she's the one
whose life took a downturn after the
incident and she even gets worse over
time when it comes to the bullies on a
positive note though I think that the
whole chain of experiences makes her
Adventure your friendship with doru and
Arisa all the more heartwarming
[Music]
it's no surprise that one piece will be
in such a personalized list being one of
my favorite series of all time any
guesses as to what moment made the list
why the punch that was heard all over
the world of course I like one piece not
just for the action of the adventure the
wacky powers in the world building but
also for the themes these include the
idealistic ones like friendship as well
as the more serious stuff that can apply
to the real world like racism mind you
it's not a trait that's exclusive to
this beloved Shonen series but it sure
does well in presenting those themes
using its extremely Colorful World such
as this incident with Luffy punching out
the Celestial Dragon it's pretty much
one of the textbook examples of racism
and bullying on display and it even took
place at a grand stage of an orchard
seeing Luffy stick up for his buddy and
not care about the ramifications is a
thing of beauty it takes real guts to do
that not even the Celestial Dragon
status spared him from this beat down
good for him though he deserved it
laughs
that's my personal list of favorite
scenes of bullies getting what they
deserved in anime I'm sure you've got a
lot more to add to this list so I'd like
to hear your input on both the picks I
made and the scenes themselves if you
enjoyed watching the video and would
like to support the channel don't forget
to check out the Channel's membership
options you can gain access to even more
videos that way you can also support me
on patreon and it will help me come up
with even better production quality on
these videos as we start moving towards
the Channel's next big milestone thank
you for watching and I hope that you had
a lot of fun I wish to see you again on
my next video so see you then
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]